es muy común escuchar un término llamado
tabulador de impuestos
tabulador
d
e impuestos de impuestos
y también es muy común que las personas
no tengan una comprensión real de lo que
esto significa y sobre esto va a tratar
este vídeo quiero explicar esto de una
manera general y sencilla no voy a
analizar el código de impuestos
particular de algún país pero la mayoría
de los países tienen algún tipo de
sistema de impuestos progresivo que
tienen algún tipo de tabulador de
impuestos digamos que en mi país hay un
código de impuestos que dice que entre
cero dólares de ingreso hasta diez mil
dólares de ingreso se paga una tasa de 0
por ciento de impuestos sobre este rango
de ingresos
y nos dice que entre 10.000 y 50.000
en este rango se tiene una tasa del 20
por ciento de impuestos y digamos que
por encima de 50 mil dólares todo lo que
esté por encima de esta cantidad se le
va a aplicar un impuesto del 30 por
ciento y ese sistema es bastante
sencillo mucho más sencillo que los
sistemas de impuestos reales la razón
por la que les digo que hay confusión
aquí es porque muchas personas piensan
que si su ingreso cae en este rango o en
este tabulador tendrán que pagar un 20%
sobre todo el ingreso que reciben pero
esto no funciona así vamos a hacer un
par de ejemplos digamos que tenemos una
columna que es de ingresos
ingresos
y aquí tenemos otra columna que es de
los impuestos que le corresponden a
estos ingresos impuestos
vamos a imaginar que una persona recibe
5000 dólares
de ingreso que impuestos va a pagar con
este ingreso bueno vemos que estamos en
este tabulador donde los primeros diez
mil dólares y cinco mil es menor a diez
mil no pagan impuestos así que va a
pagar cero dólares de impuestos ahora
imaginemos que otra persona gana quince
mil dólares
esto va a tener que pagar de impuestos
bueno se va a pagar 0% en los primeros
10 mil dólares así que va a ser 0%
multiplicado por 10 mil
dólares y los siguientes cinco mil que
entran en el segundo tabulador más o
menos por acá estos cinco mil de
excedentes son a los que se les va a
aplicar el 20 por ciento de impuestos
así que a esto le sumamos el 20 por
ciento por
5000 que es el excedente del ingreso de
esta persona y que cae en este tabulador
así que aquí no se paga impuestos y aquí
se paga el 20% nada más de los 5.000 de
excedente y esto es igual a mil dólares
de impuestos
y la confusión que tienen muchas
personas es que creen que todos estos
15.000 tienen este 20% de impuestos
cuando sólo se aplica el excedente a
aquella fracción del ingreso que cae en
este tabulador solo se paga el impuesto
del incremento que cae en este tabulador
en esta parte del tabulador al menos en
este ejemplo hagamos otro ejemplo ahora
imaginemos que hay una persona que gana
100 mil dólares
qué impuestos va a pagar alcanzamos a
llegar a este tercer tabulador pero
vamos por partes los primeros 10.000
dólares no van a pagar impuestos así que
tenemos un cero por ciento multiplicado
por los primeros diez mil dólares
y no abrevió con 10k para evitar
quedarme sin espacio más del 20% del
excedente entre 10.000 y 50.000 que son
40.000 ya que es 50.000 menos 10.000
por 40.000 que de nuevo lo abre vio como
40 cada y solo se va a pagar el 30 por
ciento de aquella porción del ingreso
que cae en este tabulador que está por
encima de los 50 mil dólares así que
100.000 menos 50 mil va a ser lo que cae
en ese tercer tabulador al que le
corresponde un impuesto del 30 por
ciento estos 50.000 dólares que abrevió
como 50 acá así que de esa parte no se
pague impuestos de esta otra parte
corresponde a pagar 8 mil dólares y de
esta parte de aquí el 30 por ciento de
50 mil es 15 mil
quince mil es lo que corresponde pagar
de impuestos en esta sección por lo que
el impuesto total es 15.000 más 8000 va
a ser igual a 23 mil 23.000 dólares y
como ven no se pagó el 30 por ciento del
total del ingreso sólo aquel excedente
que cayó en ese tercer tabulador